[Music]
book review
that's right for some reason you guys
still want me to make these
first of all i'm an idiot last month i
said we were gonna read
runaway horses and spring snow i had no
idea
they're connected they're part of a
tetralogy luckily these are the two
first ones
but if you followed me on this month of
book review
then hopefully you read them at the
right or in the right order
i usually don't like knowing anything at
all about the books that i read but i
realize
that if i'm gonna recommend books then
maybe just maybe
i should do a little bit of research so
i'm sorry
gumena say the thing is that i when i
discovered yuki mishima i did it by pure
coincidence i didn't know anything about
him and i
just fell in love with his writing and i
fell in love with finding out about
his ideas but also his life just this
the joy of discovering him was so great
that i wanted to honor that and keep
that going with what i read from him
so that's why anyway let's get into the
review phillips jeez
spring snow let's start with spring snow
in the right order hooray for me
everybody
a little bit of background i feel like
might help you understand a bit better
the author yukimishima believed in the
code of ethic of
bushido which is the samurai code of
ethic
he wanted to restore that and also
restore the power to the emperor
that's oversimplifying things but
because of it you see a lot of common
themes throughout his
novels which is around the
westernization of japan and that
major cultural shift that happened
during that period so spring snow
takes place right after that right after
the end of meiji period
now if you don't know what major period
is just google it it's hilarious
because it's the least japanese thing
you've ever seen it's just
uh people talk about cultural
appropriation just google mangy period
now i think it's important to understand
at least that
despite yukimishima being against like
many other japanese people
the westernization of japan a lot of
people still recognize
yukimishima himself that for japan to
prosper as a modern nation
they needed to borrow technology from uh
from the west and they did this in a
sort of mindset of
well japanese ideology is better but
we'll still take this western technology
and mishima himself did take a lot of
inspiration from western literature and
and so on and so forth most notably
spring snow
itself is purposely written in a western
style
it feels very familiar as opposed to his
other work
now let's get into the story i'm not
gonna spoil everything because that has
been requested to me before i just
assumed that since i said i was gonna
read the book i could discuss it in its
fullest but i realized now
uh i don't wanna ruin it for people but
a brief explanation
it follows the story of kiwaki
kiyaki misugai who
is described as young beautiful handsome
man
he has a good future ahead of him he's
born into
this previously samurai family but
that became nouveau rich because of
uh embracing uh the change the cultural
changes and
and the meiji period and the benefits
from that but
kiyoki is very childish he falls in love
with satoko
who is part of this more aristocratic
family
with higher stature and the sort of type
of family that kiyaki's
family the masagaya looks up to and
wants to be
but kiyoki doesn't really know how to
deal with his emotions for satoko
he acts like a very spoiled teenage brat
about it
at one point he loves her another point
he despises her and it sort of goes back
and forth but it's very fun to follow
this
uh around kiyaki despite being very
childish and
and so changing i remember he writes his
letter to satoko because
he has given up on her he he's lost all
faith in her and he write
he writes that in a letter to her and
then later on
he meets up with some friends and they
ask him hey do you have someone that you
love
and he describes satoko sugar
i made a big mistake i need to stop this
letter so he phones satoko
and he says whatever you do do not read
the letter that i sent you
promise me that you will burn the letter
and not read it
so later on he meets up with satoko uh
she invites him to a rickshaw
ride a bit unexpectedly you follow his
internal thoughts of did she read the
letter did she not read the letter
is she playing with me what is going on
here and um
it sounds so stupid it sounds so
uninteresting but i really really
enjoyed this
uh this bit it focuses a lot on of these
type of events that just seems
uninteresting and trivial and
unimportant but it has a charm to it
that i really enjoy
it's not until satoko is completely out
of
uh kiyoki's reach that he realizes
finally his full love for satoko
but thanks to his friend honda who is
very loyal
and trustworthy and will do anything for
kiyaki
he helps him so that he can sneak out
with
satoko and so that they can be together
at least for a little bit
that's it for the story i think that's
all you need to know to understand
the themes around the the story much
like
many other works from mishima they
reflect
certain themes each character i think
okay i think this is just me speculating
but kriyaki represents i don't know it
sounds stupid but
the new japan trying to find its foot
in this cultural shift the reason why he
doesn't really know
for sure his feelings for satiko is
because satoko represents
a sort of in between all the new japan
so sometimes he loves
satiko sometimes he doesn't he despises
her
and but because i think satoko's family
represents uh new japan new japan from
the meiji period kiyoki
himself sees his family later on in a in
a bad light because they
let go of their roots their samurai
roots in a sense i think it's really
interesting to have a novel around these
themes and ideas but the main reason
that i really loved this book was
because
of its poetic style sounds so
pretentious for me to say but it
the way it reads you really cherish the
pages
it has so many interesting personalities
most importantly
getting the inside of this very
fascinating period of time
through the eyes of kuyaki i really
enjoyed it very nice
four out of five did you read it did you
like it what did you think
runaway horses where do i begin this
book
i know it's a bit annoying but i'm gonna
preface this novel as well with some
history
because just like spring snow that
started
that the novel the spring snow takes
place right at the end of the meiji
period
runaway horses uh takes off right after
an historical event in japan which is
called the may 15
incident which really happened a cooler
name for the may 15 incident is the
blood league incident damn that's edgy
sorry league of blood
incident mishima often takes real
historical event in japan for example he
wrote the temple of the golden pavilion
which is about a monk that burned down
the temple of
the golden pavilion and he sort of
fictionalizes
a story of of what that was like for the
monk and
what went through his head and in the
similar sense
mishima did this with the runaway horses
of that
but in this time he echoes the event
instead
which will make sense later on to put it
briefly
the legal blood incident was a group of
samurai that
tried to restore power to the emperor
by killing a bunch of political people
and i'm
describing this i'm just trying to keep
it quick and
uh it failed they got captured
but so many people of japan didn't agree
with their sentencing so they
signed with blood 350 000 people signed
with blood and set it in to lessen
the sentence for uh the capture that's
just a little bit of backstory okay
let's get into it let's just
jump into it runaway horses follow the
story of isau
he is uh 17 years old he was brought up
in the
code of bushido which we know is the
samurai code of ethics
he is level 3 in kendo i don't know what
that means but i think it means he's a
badass
isau is the reincarnation of kiwaki
so this takes place 17 years after
spring snow
did i just spoil spring snow oopsie
so the character honda if you remember
he makes a reappearance
uh he's now a judge and he
meets up with isau by chance and he
realizes that he is the reincarnation of
his old friend kiyoki
isao mi isao wants to give honda his
favorite book
which is the league of the divine win
which is inspired by
another rebellion another coup d'etat
that actually happened
during the meiji period it was a group
of people a group of samurai same thing
again
revolt against the meiji government
restore power to the emperor they were a
smaller group of samurai but they were
very tactical
and used surprise to their advantage
they managed to
actually make a large impact despite
eventually failing and committing sepuku
i think
the important thing to take away from
this is that the shinpurin rebellion as
it's called
despite it being a failure and despite
them committing seppuku
it's seen as a success in the way that
it inspired other rebellions and more
afterwards it's seen as a way for a
small group of dedicated people
having a larger impact and is how the
character in the book
sorry it keep mixing fiction and and
history
which i think is what makes it so
interesting it's i was so inspired by
this book and the people
and their and their intentions giving
their life to
their cause that he wants to start his
own group in the
essence of the league of the divine wind
recruits a
bunch of younger students by showing
them
the book and asking how do you feel
about this book does this inspire you
and
he gets a very loyal group of 20 people
and he plans to do
an attack very similar to the may 15
incident it's planned out in the
intention of
inspiring other people and having as
much effect as
you can as a small group and then to
commit sepuku
so they plot to kill the country's
capitalists but before they're able to
go
forth with their plan issa gets betrayed
and that's all i need to say with the
story runaway horses
is vastly different from spring snow but
it still shares
common themes uh around the purity of
youth
versus the corruption of the adult it's
about the willingness to sacrifice
yourself for the greater good and what
you believe in
and also the envy
and jealousy of that glory of having
something worth dying for but i think
most importantly
uh the major theme of this novel is
the i don't know exactly to know
and not to act is not to truly know
yukio mishima himself
the author a well acclaimed well
regarded rich famous author
created his own uh
military the tatanokai
on the same day as he finished his
tetralogy he left the
last page in his office open he left
with
four members of his tatunokai his
military group
he went to the military tokyo
headquarters
he kidnapped the commander barricaded
himself
in the headquarters told the media to
come
and and see what he had to say and in
the hopes
of inspiring the soldiers out in the
courtyard he gave his speech
for the same reason as isau and all
these other rebellions against the meiji
period
to respond to restore glory to the
emperor yuki mishima
knew this would fail but as we know
failure doesn't necessarily mean the
ending
despite him wanting to inspire these
soldiers and despite him knowing that
they probably wouldn't listen to him
he knew that to know and not to act is
not to truly know
and he lived and died by those words so
after delivering his speech
he went inside he wrote his death poem
and he went down on his knees and
committed his death poem
and the event of his death very much
reflect runaway horses
his poem reads a small night storm blows
saying falling is the essence of a
flower
preceding those who hesitate the last
words that was left
in his final book on his desk said human
life is limited
but i want to live forever i will give
this book 5 out of 5.
ten out of ten a hundred out of a
hundred
[Music]
next up i read sapiens it was
recommended by my parents
thank you parents sapiens egg
is the telling of the story of
humankind i put all the effort into the
mishima i don't know what i'm gonna
say it tells the the major revolutions
of of human history
the cognitive the agriculture the empire
and the scientific revolution
it tells the story of mankind in a third
person perspective
as if aliens talked about us which is so
weird and bizarre but still very
gripping and interesting
i it's a super easy read it starts off
by telling historical facts about
how mankind changed throughout history
but then as we get to
closer to current time the author it's
clear that the author is putting a lot
of his own
assertions in there and it becomes a bit
blurred i will say a lot of times
without any evidence as well
reading it you kind of go
i'm not sure if i'm buying this i don't
know have you read it would you agree
with me on that
it seems that the author has
his own ideas about certain things like
capitalism and socialism and these
i guess they're complex things to
describe anyway the bias of the author
to me is clear in there at least and
that sort of mud in the waters
but regardless i really really enjoy
this book it's
super fascinating for anyone to reflect
what it's like to be a
sapience it's uh pretty fun i the
chapters that i enjoy the most was about
morals
because i never thought about how
morals have shifted so much throughout
our time
i thought i had it pretty clear what i
think is right and wrong but put me in
any other time in history
and it doesn't really match anymore what
other people think
and same thing in the future our morals
will probably be completely
different as well and it almost gave you
a sort of nihilistic
view and hopelessness of it's all
this constant shift of mankind but what
i thought was the most interesting was
talking about buddhism because i didn't
know
how aligned the morals of buddhism is
with today's society
despite being written 2 000 years ago i
think
so after reading sapiens i knew i wanted
to read more buddhism
about buddhism i previously just brushed
it away because i thought well
buddhism that's for uh unmarried women
who's going through a mid-life crisis
uh give this book three out of five by
the way but afterwards i read
in the buddha's words an anthology of
discourses from the pali canon
this book is amazing buddha never wrote
down his words they were just retold
and a lot of times ideas get shifted
and spread out too much that it's hard
to understand how to study buddhism
so this book gives a more defined frame
of the buddha's teachings
a lot of the ideas already aligned with
how i perceive
things especially how you should
perceive your emotions you should still
feel happy you should still feel anger
but you should feel it disconnected
a lot of ideas i also realized was
resembled to
dr frankl's logotherapy
from the book we read in the past
remember man search for meaning i draw
the resemblance on how you should live
your life because i remember frankel
talked about
you should perceive life as if you've
already lived it once and made all the
mistakes
because that prevents you from falling
into destructive behavior
and the buddhist karma system in a lot
of ways is similar
you live your life correctly once and
that's all you need
the goal is not to relive your life the
goal is to cease to exist and reach
enlightenment and reach nibana now you
do this in many different ways
but one of the main things is to remove
all cravings from your life
because craving leads to suffering and
suffering leads to rebirth
and to be born is to suffer and to live
is to suffer i know i'm explaining this
very poorly by the way
and the buddhist ideology around
removing craving is to uproot it
completely
because otherwise it will always be
there and only if you do that
is when you can reach enlightenment and
there's something really interesting
about that
when is enough enough i was super
fascinated by this book this is just
a very selected part of it i don't want
to get into all of it
if you're interested in buddhist
teaching this is a great book to start
off with
and if your life is sugar give it a go
can't hurt next up i wanted to get into
greek
philosophy i'm not going to just jump
into it this time this time when i'm
going to
search okay what should i know before i
i read philosophy greek philosophy and a
lot of people say okay well you should
start reading the myths
mythos with stephen fry i thought he was
just a stand-up comedian but apparently
he's an author as well
this is probably not the book i wanted
to read but i enjoyed it very much
regardless stephen fry being a comedian
you can tell
he does an excellent job at retelling
the ancient greek myths
you probably are familiar with so many
of them already and so was i
but it was still very very interesting
it's almost like reading fairy tales
in a lot of ways i would love to if i
had a kid i know it sounds so weird
i would love to read them greek
mythology because they're
they really feel like bedtime stories uh
obviously a lot of them are
inappropriate
a lot of them are based on sexual
endeavors but still
i really enjoy them because not only you
realize a lot of our language
derives from the ancient greek
mythologies like
words like chaos cronus
thanos thanos yeah that's right he means
death
i can't believe ancient greek
copied fortnight a lot of the stories
describe how phenomenon exists that they
couldn't explain
such as how did the universe come to be
about
well it was kronos before it was chaos
and oh and oh how did the first spider
come about
and these really clever interesting
stories about these things i really it's
really fun
uh definitely fun book to read
3.5 out of 5. i don't know i don't have
much to say about it it's not the book i
wanted to read but i had fun anyway
okay last but not least the inferno by
egg stringberg
or augustine by again this is not
a good introduction to aegis
strindenberg i don't know why
i picked it just because the only one i
had did you read it
i did say i was going to read it for
next month it follows
the inter the mental struggle of vega
streamberg
at his later years it was never really
confirmed what was wrong with aegis
but you read what he's writing i think
it's taken from his diary
and there's clearly some form of
paranoia
schizophrenia going on he's trying to
experiment on how to create
gold and people are paranoid about
people stealing his ideas and
it's very fascinating but very bizarre
to read like reading the notes of a
madman almost
obviously he wasn't fully crazy
something was definitely going on he was
inspired by the
the work of swedenborg svead and bori
i assume that's how it's pronounced who
described that
hell is real and you can relive it on
earth and uh iggy streamback draw a lot
of
resemblances himself to his own life to
what swedenborg described that this
would happen
and aegis realizes that he lived through
hell on earth
hence the title the inferno the real
reason i wanted to read
aegis stringberg and i want to read more
to vegas streamberry is because
uh my grandad when i was young
i used to read a lot i sort of refound
this
love for reading after being obsessed
with gaming for 10 years
when i was younger i loved reading and i
loved sharing uh
discussing books with my grandad
obviously i was really young i was like
10 or 12
so i don't know how much of a discussion
he was but he was so
happy and fascinated i liked reading uh
and i would read sherlock holmes because
he loved sherlock holmes
he tried to get me into this private
sherlock holmes group
but i was too young to really understand
i read a lot of sherlock holmes when i
was a kid
uh sadly he passed away a few years ago
so
now you know i would have loved to
discuss books with him or they would
have been amazing
and that's why i wanted to read aegis
streamberg because maybe stringberg is
one of the most famous author in sweden
it and
my granddad really looked up to him as
well so i wanted to find out more about
why
this is the wrong book to read that but
it's sad that i can't
discuss novels with my granddad but
i'm very happy at least that i can do it
here
on this channel with you guys i really
appreciate all the support
that was it for book review thank you
for watching
next month i'm just gonna pick one novel
it's gonna be
light it's gonna be easy it's gonna be a
sci-fi it was recommended by you guys so
you better pick this one up
okay it's called the forever war by joe
holdeman all the books i'll link them in
the description if you want to check
them out on amazon
i'll get a referral as well from that so
very nice and that's it thank you guys
for leaving a like and share with all
support as always
love you guys so much and as always
goodbye